is anti-globalism just anti-Semitism a
viewer named Jesse wrote to me about
this and I think it's a good opportunity
to talk about whether this entire
Obsession that the right has with how
global-ish are bad globalished
internationalist trotskyite socialists
unlike Obama Trudeau macron okay yeah
you get it whenever a right winger or a
reactionary talks about the globalist
system and the globalists and all of it
they are often actually referring to the
idea of a Jewish conspiracy to control
this that or the other thing now they
use code words to mask their intentions
and many of the people touting this
anti-globalist stuff don't even realize
that it is a thinly veiled anti-semitic
conspiracy many of them are just
regurgitating talking points that they
heard from somebody else without even
really understanding the origins or the
oranges of so-called anti-globalism
globalism exists in the in what I mean
is the idea of globalism as something
separate from Jews are doing stuff does
exist globalism is the operation and
planning of Economic and foreign policy
on a global basis right that would be
when rather than as individual countries
you have global economic planning you
have Global foreign policy planning
that's a real thing in terms of it could
be something that exists most of these
right Wingers
that talk about globalism don't actually
give a damn about real globalism as I
just described it to you for many of
them it's just another way to spread
their hateful ideology to place a Target
on particular people and it is often a
thinly veiled placeholder for
anti-semitic conspiracy theories it's
actually similar to I this is so fraught
to ever mention George Orwell's 1984
because it's so often mentioned in ways
that has actually nothing to do or have
nothing to do with what George Orwell
wrote about but when you think back to
Orwell's 1984
and you think about Goldstein as
a tool to fuel hatred towards Jews a
bogeyman or a boogeyman depending on
your preference
anti-globalism has become a similar
coded dog whistle version of
anti-Semitism and so it's a way that
right Wingers can spread their hate and
their intolerance under a more
politically correct veneer they claim to
be against political correctness they
want to just say things as they are
say things as they are for them would be
to be going after Jews but I guess they
realize they have to be a little more
politically correct maybe I don't know
and so they're calling it we're against
globalism rather than we just have these
conspiracy theories about Jews we have
seen this kind of talk before
and I know many of you know exactly
where we have to go back to and it's the
1930s and we saw where it led then
disastrous consequences for marginalized
communities including Jews and others as
well so what we really should do as we I
mean it's like okay David great many of
us suspected that anti-globalism is
really just coded anti-Semitism but what
can we actually do about it well one
thing you can do is call it out for what
it is
anti-globalism isn't this harmless
political Viewpoint it's a form of
anti-Semitism with the potential to lead
to terrible things and one idea just one
idea for how to handle it is when you
hear these folks start talking about
globalism how globalism is bad ask them
to explain exactly which policies and
initiatives they're opposed to it's very
easy for them to say well I'm against
all of the ideology of George Soros and
Klaus Bob for example
but that's not policy ask them for
policy now some may say well I'm against
dealing with climate in a global way
like for example with the Paris climate
Accords okay we could talk about Paris
climate but most of them won't actually
have any examples of the globalism they
claim to be against and what's what's
interesting is and kind of funny and sad
for people spending so much time talking
about globalism you would think they'd
be able to list at least a bunch at
least a few
globalist policies but in my experience
I would be shocked if they can actually
name a single one maybe they'll mention
Paris climate uh but of course countries
can just opt out as Trump did opt out
the United States during his presidency
so yes anti-globalism a very flimsy
veneer
for anti-semitism